thank you so much thank you so much for
having me it's quite pleasure to develop
a presentation here because I'm very
influencer influenced by Eric's work
so I'd like to celebrate with Eric's
fundamental contributions to meta
complexity so today what I'm going to
talk about is about Eric's two
conjectures so he wrote the paper in cre
with the computer the conference in
Europe and this is a paper from Eric's
um cie paper and she has this contextual
so the title of that paper is curious
and curious the link between in
compressivity and compressive
compressively and what he conducted in
his paper is that he conducted that
compressive process next and BPP can be
characterized in terms of a reduction to
deceptive chronic random string which is
denoted by R here
um this paper was quite influential to
me because I started working on
compressive Story by trying to prove
these conjectures so that was my first
paper and today I will not talk about
this first paper but I would like to
explain recent progress on these
quantities and its impact that these
conditions have on meta compressed
so what's this paper about well he
proposed to understand the relations
between two Notions of Randomness in
complex Theory and computability in
comprehensive Theory we have a familiar
notion of Randomness memory BPP remember
that this is a crossover problem that
can be sold efficiently by using
Randomness memory random coin flips
sequence
on the other hand in compatibility
Theory we have a quite different notion
of Randomness namely column of
randomness
and then what is try to do is do and try
to understand BPP through the lens of
computability or column of random
storing so that's what he proposed in
his paper
so in order to State his uh conjecture
let me Define what is common compressity
so remember that coronal compressed T is
a in the stock I'm going to use the
notation J sub U of X it's a over finite
string X is the shortest program size to
put into the string X
but for example let's consider all the
string of ranks and you can describe
this string by a short program saying
that print zero end times so the column
complexity of this string is at most log
n to represent this binary encoding Over
N plus additive constant
on the other hand under the fundamental
property of column of Randomness which
says that if you choose uniformly at
random strength then with high
probability the common compressed to
maximum namely the common compressor
over uniformly children storing power
it's close to the length of r
now so this is the idea of a thermal
complexity
but in order to formally Define the
notionable common complexity we need to
fix an interpreter U namely there are
several programming around it and
depending on what programming ranges you
use you have a slightly different
variant work chromosome prestige so in
general any for any tool you must see
you we can Define the common
compressible finite string x with
respect to the turing machine U
and we can Define as follows it's the
minimum of a discretion ranks d
such that U output x given an input D so
think of d as a program that prints X
and um it's known that if you take a
universal turing machine you can get a
chrome compressive that is the shortest
and smallest up to additive constant
more generally we can call such a turing
machine Universal so we say that the
children must see you it's Universal if
it's the smallest among any other
chromal compressed major namely for any
turing machine M and for any storing X
the common compressive defined with
respect to U is up is at most the column
composite of X defined with this quick
effect to the other turing machine plus
additive constant in that case we say
that a tuning machine's Universal and it
is known that there is a universal
tuning machine that simulates any
other Theory machine
but this is an ocean called compressity
and once you define the notional
complexity we can Define the ground the
notion of Randomness in computer
computability Theory namely called Model
randomness
so we said that the string is
chronological random if it can't be
compressed into a shorter program namely
if the common compressive X is at least
the ranks of the string itself then we
say that the string is Chromo Rand
and I'm going to use the notation R sub
k u and which is a set of strings
set of column of random strings
or example
um if you look at the all zero string of
ranks n and we saw this can be
compressed into other organ bits of a
program so you can compress it so it's
not current model of Random
with high probability it's going to be a
column of random which can be shown by a
simple counting element
now so we have
um two different Notions of Randomness
in complex Theory and computability
Theory but there is no relations among
them in the sense that the um it's easy
to see that the column of random string
is not computable so by a simple
argument you can show that Columbo
compressor is not compatible as well as
you can't compute this set in finite
steps so there is no obvious relations
among them
and what he suggested is to try to
bridge the gap these two and different
notion by considering efficient
reduction to the set of random string
so let me explain how we can bridge the
gap between
non-compatible sets and something that
is completable
so the point is that we consider
reductions to Chrome strike so let's
consider the following situation you
have a polynomial time tuning machine
which can make no additive queries to
the set of Oracle memory accessible
random strings and we would practice
sort of a problem error now you are
allowed to make no adductive queries
asking whether queue is in the set of
random string and given such a given
answer from the Oracle we would like to
decide the language error
so let's denote this Cross by
P parallel reduction to the set of
random string so this subscript parallel
means that we restricting the turing
machine to normal adaptive reductions
now
um once we Define so what we are asking
here is that what can be solved
efficiently by no adaptive asking
whether the query is in random string or
not
now Burma and 49 cross skin growth
showed that VPP is contained in this
class
every
um if you have a efficient algorithm
that sort of the L by using coin flips
you can somehow replace these coin flips
by using this Oracle chronological
Paramus storing Oracle
now the question is what's the problem
so this is in some sense one side one
side
um connection between VPP and
chronograph random string but there's a
question what is upper Army for this
class
obviously the set that set of column of
random string is not computable so there
is a
uncomfortable set in this class so there
is no obvious upper bound on on this
Plus
but what Eric suggested is to take the
intersection over our Universal turing
machine then you get somehow you get the
P space upper bound
so here what I'm asking what we are
asking for is that
um this class corresponds to
um this if if your problem is in this
class it means that you can reduce the
problem
to uh the set of random string no matter
what kind of universal turing machine
you use so in some sense this asks what
can we do this to the set of random
strings
um it is irrespective of what kind of
investor chewing machine you use
then somehow you get P space upper part
so
um given this connection yeah
if I have a polynomial time
deterministic machine like how could I
ever get an interesting response out of
a query to the kamagra framework right
yeah so if I'm going to be asking a
string isn't the complexity of the thing
going to be low necessarily why doesn't
it zero yeah that's the question I have
to go back to that maybe the string
you're given as input it's very short
because as I will grow up complexities
yeah so that's very good intuition and
where every experience iterator
yeah I will explain it in the next slide
that's very good point so yeah now we
have a role weapon so another question
is which is applied and what any contact
there is at the lower amount should be
tied
so it understood that VPP should be
characterized through the length of the
chroma complexity in in this sense
memory VPP is a set of the class of
rounded that can be no adaptivity
inclusivity
that's area code contractor and before
talking about the intuition behind this
contractor so actually the context here
the intuition behind this quantity is
what the robot asked and every explain
later but why should we care about this
conductor where there are a couple of
motivations but perhaps one of the most
important motivation is that this is
closely related to minimum search size
problem with whole thing Oracle so this
is a very the very influential paper by
Eric and others which show that if you
have such the compress it is holding or
output then it's um foreign
motivation is that Eric speculatives
that this might be an approach towards P
equals PPP conjecture
and in fact you can improve this key
space upper one if you restrict the the
power of the reduction somehow to what
is called disjunctive two-step reduction
in that case you get an upper boundary p
as well
so um yeah so by sending this condition
she speculated that this might be an
approach towards the importance context
here now let me get back to robot
um question so why this context just
seems to be true
so let's say you have a polynomial but
Reds we study ourselves to to input a
unary input 0 to the n
now
um if you consider any query that this
degree machine can make the common
compressive any query is actually order
log n
the reason is that given input to n you
can generate this set of queries in
polynomial time so you can specify each
query by having n and the index of a
query so that's why we get this upper
bar
now this means that for most of the time
you get no answer from the oracle memory
if the query the length of a query is
rather than order one then the answer
from the Oracle must be no
so that's the intuition why electrical
context seems to be true because only 0
to the N any polynomial time no other
two reduction cannot make use of any
query of ranks rather than other local
now
um let me quickly adjust complexity
classes but you have a p BPP and P Point
p and the pH remember that pH stands for
polynomial hierarchy and you have P
space now what do you like to understand
is this compressive class
and this compressive class looks very
weird and at least it's um it is
sandwiched between BPP and P space and
we directly understand what's the uh
what's this compressing for us
now um
because
um Eric's intuition is
um comes from when you redirect yourself
to input of a urinary input
so let's focus on input 0 to 0. and by a
standard padding argument in complete
Theory this is essentially equivalent to
considering an exponential time analog
of these compressed processes
so let's consider exponential time
analog of this compressive process
um so if you have a picture you get
exponential time exp here and if you
have a pH here you have exph this is the
exponential time hierarchy
now what we can show is that actually if
you look at exponential time analog the
compressive class looks quite nice nicer
compared to the polynomial
and we can actually show that this
compressive exponential time another of
this complex plus is sandwiched between
exp h8 and exp space so it's much rather
than BP exp which was conducted by Eric
so um it says paper we showed that
um exp H can be reducible to susceptible
column of random string by using
non-adaptive exponential time reduction
so what this means is that by a simple
pad environment you can repeat
the conjecture memory unless exponential
time hierarchy collapses to BP exp we
can show that
context is false namely BPP is not equal
to this compressive cross
so that's one um result about Eric's
contest
and there are other several conductors
which also tries to understand
compressive process through the range of
column of random strings
so if you consider adaptive reduction
you get a lower bound of p-space and up
around the EXP space
and similarly if you consider
non-deterministic polynomial time
reduction you get the lower bound of
next and the EXP space
and it was have conjectured that the
lower Bond should be tight
Emily
um in the hypothesis is performed by
Eric and others key space should be
characterized the set of uh the class of
problem leadership to that's the problem
and Eric also context that that next
should be characterized by using the
reductions to the set of random string
foreign
strings
so in particular
um on this exp to the NP is contained in
next p space can't be characterized by
this compressed class and the next
student will be also characterized by
this complex class
um can you repeat the question
the question is what's the intuition
behind why this contestate report or
sorry the
uh
yeah
um
yeah that's just a question so
um the nutrition is that
basically you research it to just
um asking
um other login please what other
benefits which banks queries but somehow
um you can get information such as
satisfied from the vegetable very first
subject for that
by making a query of these frames
definitely
yeah it could be
um yeah yeah I think that's much yeah if
you have a larger Gap
yeah that's a good point so um
yeah paper by
um sucks and the sansana
um
they showed that the if you restrict the
honest um honest to reduction you get
some kind of upper one some improved
upper one so yeah I think I feel
restricted to the class of uh reductions
you might still get this kind of
characterization
okay so yeah we have um this previously
we had a p space but we now have exp and
we still don't understand what's the
right answer for this
so
um let me explain the proof idea but for
different results from the same paper so
I'm going to present a proof for NP
hardness of a chromal compressed and the
quad polynomial time no adaptive
reductions
so I'm here I'm going to consider a
strategory stronger Oracle here so we
assume that the Oracle returns column
compressive query q instead of asking
the set of random string so the reason
why I'm going to present this is that in
some sense this can be seen as a NP
hardness of mcsp with a political so
that might be interesting to you and
also the proof is inspired by ITC paper
so the proof contains some idea why I
explained is force
and there are two important ingredients
for the proof so why is symmetry of
information
symmetry of information states that
chroma compressible y given X plus a
compressor of X is approximately equal
to the compressive X and Y
and another ingredient in the proof is
what is called k-wise diagram generator
so let me explain what is this generator
but direct product which I'm going
to denote by DP subject is the following
very simple function
so this function takes a string X and Z1
up to GK and it output the map to decay
and it also activated G1 speed over the
error corrected version of the function
of the X
so here Inc is a some list recordable
evaporating code
and it outputs a string of ranks two to
the parameter so you can think of the I
as a index to the to the string so it's
a bit of a string and here you have the
GI speed of elaborative code code of x
and it is not that we can choose um era
quality call to Output polynomial
ranks so we ask we can assume that
Lambda is order program or order okay
so if you know what is a pseudonym of
Delta Construction and this can be think
of a surrounded construction based on a
hardware stable of X and this pseudonym
generator takes a seed of Lambda tablets
and extend it to add by kvit so without
the Lambda K plus k
and the reason why we call this uh
surround data construction is a record
that we have a reconstruction procedure
for this diagram generator
so what it says is that let's say you
have a Oracle B and you have a string X
and let's say we can distinguish the
pseudonymous sequence the piece of
kilometer uniform distribution
in that case
you can show that there is a compressed
representation of X of other laminate
tablets so here I haven't explained what
is time value treatment compressive but
this says that the time bounded formal
compressive is of X it at most other
laminate k
and what it means is that there is a
polynomial time program with d Oracle of
length or diameter K bits that prints
are X
in other words
um it might be easier to understand this
in the control positive way so if you
take the control positive it means that
if you don't have any compressed
representation of X then you cannot
distinguish the pseudonymous sequence
from the uniform distribution so that's
why we call this pseudonym data
Construction
and the proof of this uh the
construction is just a simple hybrid
document uh which you can improve by
yourself if you are funny how many
familiar with student Anonymous but in
this talk let's assume that this is
um true and let's see how we can improve
entity hardness of chromal compressed
let's say you have a run this error that
you want to solve and you have a
verifier for the rung is and let's say
you have our input X
and let's say you have a
um so the idea of the proof is that we
would like to find the first certificate
basic property First Site certificate on
input X and on Essence stands for
so let's say y sub X is the first
certificate and the goal is to find the
third field
now how can we do that well the idea is
to try to distinguish the strong gender
construction that is instantiated with Y
sub X from the uniform distribution
so the idea behind this is that if you
know the electrical very first
certificate you can distinguish this
surround sequence from the uniform
distribution
so that's a kind of high level intuition
um now since we have a column of
compressed Oracle it's natural to try to
break this wrong generator by using by
measuring column complexity of the
string
so let's measure polymer compressible X
and the DP sub K which is instant
situated with Y sub X
now we can bound this complexity by
Coronado compressed of X plus the length
of the C to Z and are the log K bits in
order to encode K here
so the reason why this is true is that
let's say you have a program that prints
X
now you have X
and if you have X you can find by using
exhaust research you can find y sub X
now if you are different with Z as well
you can compute the direct product
so in this way we get to this upper
bound
now remember that the seed length is K
times Lambda where Lambda is order when
so we get this upper one
on the other hand we also have a row of
Art
let's say instead of a direct product
generator
we let's consider a uniform distribution
W
in this case by using a symmetry
modification we can go around this by
column compressible X plus the common
compressive W given X
and if we choose W from the uni home
distribution then by a simple counting
element we can see that this column
compresses close to the length of the w
under the length of a w is a k Lambda
times K so we get this slightly
digestion uh try to read as a threshold
so this means that if we measure promote
compress of these stories we can
distinguish serial random sequence for
if you choose K to be sufficiently large
MIT can be chosen to be ordered
we can define a
Oracle as follows let's say you have a
special s here and we can Define oracle
DX as follows it output one if only
compressive X and W is small
and by this argument we know that this
output 1 on every input in the range of
direct that direct products generator
and from the second argument we can show
that the uh if you get any home input
then you get um you have to put one with
with small probability
Now by using the Reconstruction
procedure
we get a compressed representation of
the retrography first subject
then we um y sub X polymer compressor y
sub X is at most other K times parameter
and the K is all right N and ramna is
overall n so we get the upper bound of
order Logan squared
so now we get um efficient argument for
solving NP
um the algorithm is quite simple the
given X we just try to find a radical
very first certificate
by applying all possible compressed
representation of the Y sub X namely we
apply all positive possible polynomial
time program outside log N squared and
check with the it is a certificate for X
in the es instance
but that's the proof
um
so in order to get uh the resulting in
ITC test paper this is a in some sense
special test in which you consider X
being reunary
and in that case the threshold s becomes
order when so in some sense you get uh
much you can replace column compressive
Oracle with the Oracle of the set of
random strings
another special case is to is a case of
X is chosen randomly from the uniform
distribution and in this case we also
get the heuristic algorithm for sort of
in the NFP by using the set of random
string as an oracle the reason is that
you get in this case the threshold can
be chosen across to the Maxima
that's a um idea
so um this so naturally you get some
kind of average Sr version and this
paper led me to writing another paper
which connects two areas of a compressed
Theory
so one area is average is compressible
pH which is pioneered by the work of
rabbit
for example one with the fundamental
question in compressed theory is whether
pH is a hard on average
another
um question in compressor is what is a
meta compressed of computing
time-bounded column compressed so this
is a pioneered by um Theory code and the
paper and the questions a specific
question you might ask is what is a
compressive approximating creative
Oracle time bounded compressed
and by using the idea developed in the
previous work and in a fox paper we were
able to establish the equivalence
between these two questions
so
um we get um in top disciplinary link
between uppercase compressive and was
just compressed then with the following
statements are equivalent
uh why is that a distribution of pH is
not in average P which means that the pH
is hard on average and this is
equivalent to the Vasquez hardness of
approach meeting on ph Oracle time Bond
inter polymer compressed which is pH
so why this is um interesting well from
the perspective of meta compressed this
result classifieds the compressor with
Japanese pH as a distribution of pH
complete problems and this is in the
sense of this equivalence
and from the perspective of averages
compressive this provides a new proof
techniques of analyzing average
compressive by using meta compressed
so under other specific application we
get the hardness application system for
pH
so in the next slide let me explain what
is Japanese pH
and minkity which is defined by called
the paper it's the the problem is a
problem of computing the time bounded
complexity
and T time bundle compressible X is the
length of a shortage program that brings
X in t steps
and Min KT is a problem of computing a t
time value to Chrome compressity
and naturally we can consider a Oracle
variant of the of the problem if it is
called Minka t2j
so we can generalize P time one column
complexity to a Oracle time by the
Chrome compressed so instead of asking
the shortest problem that prints X and
we are considering a Oracle shortest
program that prints X and this is
denoted by K Sub Factory T and x a
admitted a is a problem of computing a
Oracle time management compressed
um you might imagine that a should be
deducible to mean KT to the a but this
is unfortunately this is not known and
it would have a significant advice case
if you can prove this
and it's easy to see that this is a
problem in npta
um let me State this result more
slightly more formally so this statement
means that for every Oracle a in PH that
means it is a is in P namely you can
approximate a Oracle time value to
promote complexity in polynomial time
and here Gap means that we are allowing
other organic additivity error yeah in
the approximation
and as a quarry of this equivalence we
get the new techniques of analyzing
averages compressed by using meta
compressed
so what what this this person asks is
that
um let's say you have um average
algorithm for pH that succeeds on one
percent of the fraction of inputs then
can we get uh average algorithm that
succeeds 1990 percent of the algorithm
is equal to how average is Harden sample
equation
and in order to prove this so this can
be uh get obtained by other query of
this equivalence
and we under this equivalence can be
proved as false
first you use uh assuming that pH is
easy on others and this algorithm
succeeds on just one percent of inputs
you use a vastus averages reduction to
get the worst case approximate thing
otherwise
which I will not explain today
but then by if you have a efficient
algorithm that application formal
compressive then you get them averages
algorithm that serves pH so this is
based on on the on the ideas developed
in defeating Eric's conductor and the
proof is pretty much the same with the
previous proof so let me explain how we
can move from worst case meta complexity
to averages compressed
so the trophy is quite
similar to the previous one so let's say
uh the application is the mp3p and let's
say
we'd like to prove that this NP is easy
on average
we haven't explained what is a system p
is but what I'm claiming is that
previously I'll reconsidered the worst
case input but now we are taking a uni
home Runway input and the view director
shows that you can solve NLP on average
for random input
so that the pro the proof is quite
similar to the previous one and the the
difference is emphasized in react
again the goal is uh the same so
redirect this thing is a direct block
generator
but now we don't have time uh time
unbonded to call mobile compressive
worker instead what we have is a sub
Oracle time bonded to Kernel compressed
I'm going to show you how to distinguish
a direct vertical generator by using NP
Oracle timers
so the point is that previously we
didn't have any time Bond now we have a
polynomial time bound
and if you in order to find a fast
certificate it takes exponential time
but if you have a subtle given X you can
find the first certificate in polynomial
time
so we can use the same calculation as
before and we get the upper bound of n
plus parameter
on the other hand if you consider uh or
if in order to lower bound Karma
compressive X and the w we use a simple
config argument because here and we get
a lower band of n plus kilometer plus
and just as in the previous proof we can
show that the disk time requirement
compressive can distinguish direct block
generator from the uniform distribution
now uh we just add in the previous case
we can define an oracle this of x to
Output one If Only Time 1 total more
compressible x and double is somehow
small
and then we can show that the we get a
compressed representation of Y sub X
and
if you apply the previous reconstruction
you get something like other logo and
squared but you can improve this by
using compressed solid surround
generator and this adapter is the most
technical part in the paper but let's
forget about it
um now you get the upper amount of K
plus o w n which is the order again
so we can we get to the following simple
algorithm
give me a random input X we just
animated all possible polynomial time
program or besides order again and we
take with the
um the
output of the universal turing machine
is a certificate for the X being error
so in this way since it takes two to
order in time to exhaust the the exhaust
research you get a heuristic polynomial
time algorithm point
and so yeah so where is the randomness
of x
yeah that's a good point
um
where does the randomness is used is
um basically here
um so we in this part we get the upper
bound of N and on the other hand we need
our upper bound a lower band of n here
and the way we are you here is that uh
we use a column time or multiple
complexity so that's why
um we get we need to
um this only for holds for uh random
input X
yeah that's right
the
uh
[Music]
so the question why we are using that
very a good point so direct products
there that I'd say if it's the minimum
advice compresses here so this is called
otherwise compressed and the direct
generator is in some sense optimal in
the sense that it um it's just a k which
is the extension of the seed
so
in this context it's better to use
direct products generator
[Music]
um
yeah if you if you haven't if you can
Define oracle that business
then yeah
now um
this idea led me to get
um new Vasquez to apertures connection
which is a substitute the paper in stock
20 environment and 21. and and in this
paper we get a new uh basket upgrade
explanation for example assuming that PX
requires the time compressed the two to
the other environment then uh pH is hard
on average
and the similarly here I'm n is the
strength of the problem
and similarly we can show that NP if the
NP requires the time comparative or the
environment when the NP is hard on
average in a certain sense so here
average server BP is a notion that
interprets vasculars compressed vasque
SP and the average speed and this is a
informally speaking this is the cost of
a problem that can be solved by average
exponent time
um whose running time can be estimated
efficiently
so in some sense this x could a strong
variant of a heuristic
so um let me explain how we can prove
this kind of result so the pro idea is
quite similar to the previous one so
let's say we'd like to prove that
assuming that pH is easy we'd like to
sort of pH in the last case
and just like as before we use the idea
of meta compressed as a guitarist and
first we use vascular directors
reduction to get some Vasquez algorithm
to approximate pH Oracle tomorrow
compressive
and then again by using the idea that I
showed um in the previous proof
um we can consult what is called
Universal heuristic scheme which is some
worst case in some sense baskets are
going for a bit
and then we can get a worst case
studying that runs in two to Zoda and by
open
so I haven't time to explain the detail
but if you are interested and there's my
topic in it this is operating so please
refer to that paper
um so going back to Eric's conjecture
um unfortunately we haven't been able to
characterize BPP from the perspective of
the reduction to democracy but if you
consider no interactive statistics they
will notice nisdk we were able to give a
characterization so this is a joint work
with Eric and Hershey and we were able
to show that no interact with static
their knowledge can be characterized as
the process of desirable ranges that can
be reduced to approximation of a column
of random string in certain sense we can
also characterize uh non-intellectual
statical zero knowledge with Rogue space
verifier
by using a reduction to form of random
strings where the reduction is
randomized at any c0 so it's quite
efficient reduction
so we still uh we haven't been able to
find any uh
application of this characterization but
that's a nice open question
so in conclusion
I am very influenced by Alexis and I
would like to celebrate Eric's
fundamental contribution to meta
compressed thank you so much Eric
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
yeah so um this is a set of programs
right but you have uh this is the final
in terms of uh
application in the sense that yes
instances
is
a set of
um
correct so
foreign
yeah
sorry
with small thermal compressed and you
get some
um
students right
so so this is a promise problem and if
we have a efficient reduction to these
problems problem that chapter is
easier Which experiences
it's uh there's a if you do a party
there's a landline particular Junction
please check never is usually change the
distress so it's not so important well
threshold
respect
yeah yeah right
um
[Music]
so previously we considered uh any
we take the intersection over any
universal turing machine but now
um we are allowing errors so this you
don't have to take intersection of our
University
and this makes more green one okay thank
you
has anyone studied like I guess classes
uh of like problems reducible to like
instead of deciding uh our like uh K
complexity like producing uh
random case string like what problems
having an oracle that like gives you a
strength
yeah I think that's a good question but
I don't think
is it easy to see why you need to go to
the hierarchy
good question so in some sense
we are losing one quantifier in this
reduction because it definitely get into
the MB is a problem in Sigma to B so
it's a second level but there are the
conclusion you get is just the password
so that's why we get
um yeah we don't have good
characterization for averages
compressible and so
um
okay
yeah this characterization we need to go
up and pH because if you bother this
requirements you build one level higher
let's check other questions the coffee
breaker let's name switch again
let's have a 10 10 minute coffee break